[Music]
thing is I'm kind of in love with you is
the thing
did you know Chris Sullivan aka Toby
from this is us is in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 there's very few people who
even worked in this movie who recognize
me
how about Miley Cyrus yep in the Marvel
Universe there's no shortage of cameos
and the biggest stars in Hollywood
rendered unrecognisable so let's take a
closer look at who you may be missed and
you've been warned we're entering the
spoiler zone cuz I'm not gonna talk
about it tonight but after the show
you'll know what I'm talking about
without giving too much away David
Hasselhoff does make an appearance in
guardians 2 and even recorded a little
rap for the end credits called guardians
Inferno and there's a returning cameo
what do you let it lick you like that
for gross Seth Green once again provides
the voice of Howard the Duck what have
you brought today you tell me Jeff
Goldblum won't fully bring it as the
grand master until thor ragnarok
but we do get a quick first look during
the credits let's talk about a certain
post credit scene where we meet star
Hawk played by Sylvester Stallone's team
featuring drumroll please Michelle Yeoh
Ving Rhames
Michael Rosenbaum and the voice of Miley
Cyrus every tease that we have at the
end of the credits is something that's
meant to become a bigger part of the
Marvel cosmic universe as we move
forward into the next decade Michael
Rosenbaum is a guy who is one of my
close friends and he is so excited for
this movie to come out and for the
potential of his character to go on
that's a pretty big character in the
comics so for him to be able to do this
is really something that he's excited
about and as far as the Ravagers who had
plenty of screen time that's Steve Agee
and Chris Sullivan yes Chris Sullivan
from this is us plays taser face a lot
going on there's about two and a half to
three and a half hours of beautiful
makeup that that I got to get to wear to
to bring this character to life
taser face yes I can't talk about Marvel
cameos
at least mentioning Stanley of course
he's in there I just trust that you
probably didn't miss him let me know
your favorite guardians of the galaxy to
cameo over on Twitter or you can leave a
comment below
thanks for watching
[Music]
you